the start of the pandemic thousands of
nevadans you may be at home have lost
your job and that means paying the rent
or your mortgage
is a real challenge now for months here
in nevada there's been an order a
protective order that has banned
evictions but the moratorium ends
tomorrow
and thousands of you could find
yourselves losing your house
jim berktold is joining us live again
this morning from legal aid center of
southern nevada from
zoom or on zoom i should say jim good to
see you again this morning thanks for
joining us
good morning glad to be here well let's
get to the numbers here the gwen center
looked at this they say is about 140
000 nevada households could face
evictions
talk about the need right now to try and
find a solution for these homeowners for
these tenants
considering this moratorium ends
tomorrow we're right up on it now
sure yes yeah the eviction landscape
right now is desperate as you can
imagine
there are good people working behind the
scenes trying to put
programs in place to help homeowners and
renters but we just simply ran out of
time
the uh rental assistance program uh
through the state and through the county
is no longer accepting applications
they're working on the backlog that's
already been submitted
there was during the special session the
legislature passed sb1 which would allow
the court to prop
up a landlord tenant mediation program
to let landlords and tenants sit down
and try to work something out
that hasn't been in place yet they're
still working on that so as i said we
simply ran out of time
so right now if you are a homeowner or a
renter there not are not a lot of
options out there if you are
a homeowner you should still contact
your lender to see if potentially
you're able to get a forbearance on your
mortgage payments
that would definitely assist you but for
renters there's not a lot of options
so there aren't a lot of options but
that suggests that there are
some is there anything that that someone
who's watching at home can do
if they didn't get the the benefit
package from the county or from the
state
and you know here we are at the uh
almost at the beginning of september and
they need to pay their rent
so there as far as i know there are no
rental assistance programs available
right now
until until the existing programs work
through the backlog so really all i can
tell renters right now
is familiarize yourselves with the re
with the eviction process so that you
understand how it works
if you haven't already reach out to your
landlord potentially you and your
landlord can work out some kind of
repayment plan or some kind of option
to allow you to remain in the home um
watch your door
make sure you respond to any eviction
notice you receive
there also may be some protection still
available under the federal cares act if
you live in a property that falls under
the cares act
so you can go online and research to see
if potentially you could get another 30
days
in the home that is absolutely something
you should do
but other than that all i can recommend
is contact the governor
contact your state and local elected
officials
and just let them know your story and
let them know what kind of disaster is
going to happen
if this eviction moratorium lifts and
there are widespread
evictions in homelessness across the
state that is uh that is cold comfort
certainly for
viewers watching at home so just from
your experience over legal aid are you
expecting or
is there any hope that on a state level
or on a more local level
something is going to step in here at
the last minute
to help folks who are facing losing
their home
we don't know we are keeping our fingers
crossed we are hopeful
but at this point we don't know we are
receiving hundreds and hundreds of calls
every day
from renters tenants homeowners who are
literally
in tears saying you know i've been
struggling to get unemployment put food
on the table
and now i don't know where i'm going to
live and i don't know what to do and
honestly there's
there's not much we can tell them at
this point well it's very unfortunate
situation as we said maybe up to 140 000
folks in jeopardy right now across the
valley
jim berkton thank you for joining us you
can reach out to legal aid if you at
home are interested in some assistance
and
hopefully something happens to step in
here appreciate you joining us this
morning